bonsoir bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu sur
tv fil 78 le journal de la rédaction
voici les titres de ce lundi à 23 juin
la préfecture des yvelines ont tourné
pédagogique auprès des entrepreneurs
sont développées lors de différentes
réunions auprès des patrons les
principaux points du pacte de
responsabilité
simplification administrative allègement
du coût du travail au menu aujourd'hui à
la chambre des métiers à versailles le
solar decathlon débutera le 28 juin
quinze jours de compétition
internationale pour mettre au point la
maison de demain les participants
réalisent actuellement les prototypes
avant l'arrivée du public de cent mille
personnes attendues êtes vous favorable
au don d'organes une journée pour
réfléchir ce sera demain 24 juin à
l'initiative de l' agence de biomédecine
seul un français sur deux a fait savoir
à son entourage qu'il était pour ou
contre le don d'organes le concernant à
nous en parlerons avec pascal tiré du
centre hospitalier de versailles
l'association broadband 78 interpelle le
président du conseil général des
yvelines pierre bédier à travers une
opération baptisée touche pas à ma fibre
elle souhaite que les dispositions
prises par son prédécesseur alain
schmitt ce soit respecté le schéma
directeur territorial d'aménagement
numérique prévoit 157 millions d'euros
d'argent public pour construire un
réseau de télécommunication à très haut
débit en fibre optique couvrant les 158
communes rurales des yvelines d'ici 2020
et il semblerait que ce chantier
prennent du retard l'association lance
une enquête en ligne pour que les
principaux concernés puissent s'exprimer
une conférence de presse en visiophonie
doit aussi se tenir le 30 juin
le pacte de responsabilité expliqué aux
entrepreneurs aux employeurs ce lundi
midi une réunion avait lieu à la chambre
des métiers est pour l'instant tous ne
sont pas convaincus du bien fondé de
cette réforme olivier maniscalco et
patrick jacques de dixmude le pacte de
responsabilité présenté aux
entrepreneurs yvelinois c'est lors d'une
réunion ce lundi à la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat de versailles que
chef d'entreprise et représentants de
l'état avait l'occasion d'échanger
autour de la nouvelle réforme qui
s'appliquera de la rentrée 2014 à la fin
du mandat président
ciel en 2010 cette baisse du coût du
travail crédit d'impôt pour les
entreprises ou simplification des
démarches fiscales
a priori le pacte de responsabilité a de
quoi séduire les entrepreneurs pourtant
durant la réunion le ton monte
rapidement augmenter les impôts t il
payant des entrepreneurs mécontents
devant un nouveau changement de
fiscalité trop fréquent selon eux il
faut dire que pour un chef d'entreprise
difficile de prévoir sur le long terme
quand on ne sait pas ce dont la
fiscalité de demain sera fait j'ai fait
des travaux d'agrandissement dans mon
entreprise
nous on a pris un crédit sur dix ans on
a acheté les locaux on a acheté le
terrain c'est sur 15 ans on peut pas
raisonner sur deux ans on fait des
prévisionnels ses hauts faits des
prévisionnels sur plusieurs années on ne
se base pas sur deux ans on ne peut pas
gérer sur deux ans si on veut avancer si
on vit au jour le jour dans ce cas là on
n'a pas de projet c'est à dire qu'on ne
fait pas complètement on ne se projette
pas dans l'avenir ou surtout pas on ne
se projette pas dans l'avenir en france
autre problème abordé le financement de
ce pacte de responsabilité
certes aujourd'hui l'état accorde un
crédit d'impôt aux entreprises mais les
investisseurs s'attendent à un retour de
bâton prochainement ça donne un souffle
ça donne un souffle aux entreprises mais
bon tout ce qu'on nous a pris en amont
est ce que ça va être restituée par
cette nouvelle ce nouveau pacte
puisqu'on n'a pas l'ensemble des mesures
qui vont là on a les mesures positives
derrière ça il ya le financement donc
que vous avez vu mais mes collègues sont
très inquiets sur comment financer
puisque on met en avant
des 30 milliards d'euros 40 milliards
d'euros cet argent n'est pas dans les
caisses de l'état donc la répartition
va-t-elle profiter plus à nos artisans
on est dans l'expectative du côté de la
préfecture qui présentait cette réforme
aujourd'hui on comprend l'inquiétude de
ses chefs d'entreprise tout en se
voulant rassurant
la crise est difficile donc il est
normal que circonspect mais si vous
écoutez bien vous verrez que tel
entrepreneurs grâce aux cice contrat
enfin crédit d'impôt compétitivité à
recruter un apprenti de plus que tel
autre entrepreneur sera soulagé de deux
temps de travail pour établir ses
déclarations mensuelles que tel autre
aura bénéficié d'une mesure et en aura
aura investi sur une nouvelle machine
c'est ça qui est important selon les
prévisions du gouvernement le pacte de
responsabilité devrait d'ici 2017
permettre la création de 190 mille
emplois en france politique avec le
déplacement demain et pour quatre jours
d'une délégation de la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'assemblée
nationale
en iran le député des yvelines le
socialiste jean philippe mallet sera
présent jean philippe mallet membres de
la mission d'information sur le proche
et moyen-orient
cette visite est une première pour la
france depuis quatre ans il devrait être
question de la situation politique
régionale mais aussi du nucléaire
élections au parti radical sa campagne
de terrain notamment dans les yvelines
n'aura pas suffi rama yade a été battu
par laurent hénart l'ancien ministre de
nicolas sarkozy mais a récolté que 39%
des voix des militants face à l'actuel
maire de nancy
mais celle qui siège au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france parle de et
l'illégitimité de laurent hénart la
demande et que des vérifications
approfondies soient faites en raison dit
elle de graves irrégularités
le chantier du solar decathlon a débuté
à versa et c'est sur le site des
matelots au qu'une vingtaine d' équipes
représentant 16 nationalités différentes
se montrent depuis maintenant une
semaine leur prototype de maison solaire
cette compétition internationale on le
rappelle a lieu tous les deux ans
étudiants architectes et ingénieurs donc
quelques jours pour termites maintenons
les travaux avant l'arrivée du public
viendra ensuite le temps de l'examen des
réalisations par un jeu
deux professionnels olivier maniscalco
et j'en attends willeman font le point
derniers préparatifs avant l'ouverture
du solar decathlon 2014 7 à versailles
sur le site des matelots que les vins
technip représentant 16 nationalités
différentes monte depuis le 16 juin leur
prototype de maison solaire pour cette
compétition internationale qui a lieu
tous les deux ans étudiants architectes
et ingénieurs disposent de 11 jours pour
parachever leurs oeuvres alors pour que
tout soit opérationnel le jour j les
équipes travaillent jour et nuit
d'arrache-pied souvent au détriment du
sommeil chantier on a commencé lundi
dernier c'est déjà cinquième jour il me
semble on existe on est sur un système
de 3,8 trois équipes ont tourné je suis
du matin érection de la lys un peu
difficile pour la nuit ce qui fait moins
chaud qu'ils ont du mal à dormir
et c'est de pas prendre de retard
puisque tout est calé heure par heure
les projets présentés en novembre 2013 à
paris sous forme de maquette prennent
donc aujourd'hui taille réelle le
résultat est surprenant et le concept de
certaines maisons révolutionnaire comme
ici sur le projet livly bout les
architectes ont imaginé une habitation
plug and play sous forme de capsules
mobile est interchangeable une maison
individuelle ou un bureau viendrait se
connecter au web à l'instar d'une clé
usb sur un ordinateur
le hub ici en forme de cube de béton
fourniret alors chauffage téléphonie ou
ventilation à l'habitat lors de sa
connexion nomade moins en moins de place
les personnes changent de plus en plus
de fonctions se mute d'une ville à une
autre et les habitations peuvent
finalement avoir plusieurs rôles
un jour ça peut être un bureau louis nos
jours ça peut être une habitation
finalement tous les logements
actuellement à paris qui seront utilisés
pour du bureau et qui reste vide pour
être utilisés si ils sont construits
selon ce passé si le projet parisien
livre libre s'annonce comme un candidat
sérieux à la victoire pour ce solar 2014
d'autres projets devraient surprendre
les deux cent cinquante mille visiteurs
attendus dès le 27 juin jour de
l'inauguration officielle afin
d'encourager le don d'organes une
journée nationale de sensibilisation va
se dérouler demain mardi 24 juin
en france 50 % de la population n'a pas
en forme et ses proches de ses volontés
en la matière nous allons parler dans un
instant avec la coordinatrice au don
d'organes du centre hospitalier de
versailles
mais voici déjà un extrait du spot
réalisé par l' agence de biomédecine
à l'occasion de cette campagne cette
année je suis avec vous ce soir car j'ai
une chose à vous dire une chose toute
simple une chose importante je voudrais
vous demander de dire à vos proches si
vous souhaiter au nom donner vos organes
et voudrais vous demander de l'indien
maintenant autant c'est le bon moment
parce qu'une carte de donneur ça ne
suffit pas parce que trop de familles ne
connaissent pas le choix de leurs
proches cet appel pour une chose très
importante
simple et juste pour te dire je suis ok
pour donner mes organes non mais c'est
pas pour déconner c'est pas et si jamais
il m'arrive quelque chose je veux que tu
saches que je suis d'accord
comment sa fille non chérie les cheveux
c'est pas un organe oui tous les temps
mais non mais ne passe pas maman je te
le dis à toi et tu lui diras voilà
simplement parce que les gens se servent
aussi à ces îles sont deux buffets de
moi-même tu vois vie non si je suis
morte je pourrais pas répondre chéri oui
même tu l'as moment pour tu le dis si
jamais m'arrive un truc c'est tout la
mort empêche la téléphonie non on suit
la longe le gang don d'organes il suffit
de le dire maintenant c'est un sujet
très sérieux que nous allons aborder à
présent bons scores pascal tirez vous
êtes d'affermir coordinatrice au don
d'organes au centre hospitalier de
versailles
bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau on a vu
des images de ce clip les artistes qui
se sont mobilisés pour cette cause et on
va évoquer tout de suite ce paradoxe 85%
des français qui se disent favorables au
don d'organes et 50% de la population
qui n'a pas encore déclaré
son choix comment ça s'explique c'est un
tabou peut-être encore aujourd'hui de
parler de la mort et du don d'organes
moi je pense que c'était il reste encore
un gros tabou à ce niveau là les
chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes très peu la
plupart des gens sont d'accord sur le
principe du don d'organes mais quand il
s'agit de se positionner les gens n'y
pensent pas ne le font pas ce qui pose
de gros problèmes lorsqu'on a les
entretiens avec les proches parce que
quand les proches ne savent pas ce que
la personne décédée voulait la réflexion
qu'on entend très souvent c'est je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils voulaient je ne
prends pas la décision à sa place donc
on se retrouve avec des taux de refus
toujours supérieure à 30% en france
quasiment ce taux là aussi dans les
yvelines et même à versailles et c'est
très dommage parce que le nombre des
personnes en attente d'un organe vital
sont des organes vitaux ne cesse
d'augmenter d'une manière exponentielle
extrêmement inquiétante la carte de
donneur ne suffit pas alors la carte de
donneur c'est bien parce que c'est la
preuve d'un engagement
ce n'est pas un document officiel mais
pour nous coordinateur passe à des
proches à être peut-être un point
d'ancrage qui nous permet effectivement
d'aborder plus facilement de sujets à
côté de ça il est clair que quelqu'un
qui prend sa carte va systématiquement
en parler à sa famille comme on le dit
dans le reportage on pourra pas sa carte
comme ça en catimini
le plus souvent on le dit à ses proches
et c'est vrai que ne pas se positionner
de son vivant s'est reportée sur les
proches dans un état de grande détresse
qu'il faut réagir très vite en plus il
faut qu'on arrive à la nuit suivant la
famille à la main il faut qu'on aille
très vite donc c'est reporter cette
décision sur des gens qui parfois ne
sont plus en état de décider ne sont pas
un état de décider c'est trop dur
quels sont les besoins aujourd'hui
justement en matière de greffe et donc
de dons il ya des personnes qui décèdent
aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'y a pas de
grève possible parce que vous attendez
ses organes vitaux
malheureusement oui malheureusement oui
on déplore des décès tous les ans au
delà des 500 personnes faute d'organes
disponibles
on déplore aussi et ça les chiffres de
10 ne traduisent pas très bien le nombre
de personnes qui sont retirés biz
attendre parce que il attendait
attendait attendent une grève dès lors
il s'aggrave
leur état général s'aggraver il arrive
un moment où ils ne sont plus faire et
femmes
donkey son retrait de la liste
d'attentes alors que s'il a été griffé
plus tôt ça aurait pu être extrêmement
bénéfique
on va continuer à évoquer le don
d'organes après à cette question du jour
c'est notre micro-trottoir aujourd'hui
que savez vous du don d'organes vos
réponses je crois qu'il faut
s'enregistrer
mais je crois surtout qu'il faut faire
connaître sa décision à ses proches
si on peut l'aider quand même les
enfants qu'ils en ont besoin dit pas si
on peut choisir de le faire normalement
on peut pas vous prendre des organes si
vous n'avez pas dit que vous vouliez
bien que c'est une oeuvre humanitaire
toute personne peut être se sentent
qu'on s'entend peut-être le faire que le
faire il n'y a pas si ma fille aussi un
cousin aussi ma femme s'il importe de la
famille proche il a besoin de sa bassine
si je le voie qui s'offre et mon mieux
ça s'est pas mal passé d'efforts parce
que moi j'ai un ami fait des décédés
avant de mourir il a dit lawrence et
devrait paraître naturel france ça
devrait paraître naturel mais ça ne
l'est pas encore on l'a vu tout à
l'heure ça reste malgré tout à un tabou
il ya des réels besoins d'où cette
journée de mobilisation demain à travers
la france il ya notamment d une
opération qui est organisé sur le centre
hospitalier de versailles on va y venir
mais juste vous venez souvent sur ce
plateau on réexplique régulièrement
comment ça fonctionne mais comment se
passe le don d'organes justement pour
assurer aussi peut-être les gens une
fois qu'ils sont décédés comment ça se
passe vous intervenez vous prélevez qui
reste le récupère ses organes comment ça
marche alors c'est une procédure qui
sont extrêmement claires aux niveaux
déjà de la législation les lois de
bioéthique sont des lois extrêmement
importante suivie à la évidemment à la
lettre à partir du moment où une
personne est en état de mort cérébrale
constaté certifié par des examens
extrêmement pointue et qui sont tout à
fait conformes à au texte de loi
les coordinateurs intervienne pour faire
des entretiens avec les proches savoir
ce que la personne
on pensait alors il ya toujours deux
solutions ou la personne en avait parlé
c'est très clair que ce soit louis ou
non la décision avait été prise avant
mais comme j'étais tout à l'heure la
plupart des gens n'ont pas parlé là nous
avons des entretiens qui sont parfois
très court c'est non sans ouverture
possible pour discuter et puis
quelquefois effectivement au regard de
la vie que menait la personne de sa
générosité de son ouverture aux autres
les preuves sont amenés à dire oui mais
c'est toujours très difficile après la
prise en charge continue toujours en
relation avec l' agence de biomédecine
qui elle connaît les receveurs un
équivalent elle décide et qui va
recevoir les organes et puis après au
bout d'un certain temps après avoir fait
beaucoup d'examens sanguins des radios
des échographies etc
les organes peut être attribuée et on va
aller au bloc opératoire
ce qui est important de retenir c'est
que c'est une terre rançon chirurgicale
comme les autres comme si la personne
était vivante avec un respect est
extrêmement important de la place du
défunt quarante mille personnes vivent
grâce à un don d'organes actuellement si
je ne trompe pas donc dans les chiffres
mais on se passe le quotidien pour eux
le quotidien se passe le plus souvent
bien un il ya toujours des problèmes de
rejet est évident que ces personnes vont
prendre des comprimés contre le rejet
toute leur vie mais il y avait une image
assez symbolique à une époque un jeune
homme qui avait effectivement dans une
main les comprimés qu'il devait prendre
et puis de l'autre côté les médailles
qu'il avait réussi je crois que c'était
au tennis de table à gagner dans le
sport qui pratiquait avant après ce sont
des gens qui vivent qu'ils doivent
prendre plus de précautions que les
autres parce qu'ils soient un petit peu
plus sensibles mais la vie reprend
reprend son cours normalement centre
hospitalier de versailles demain
opération de sensibilisation dans le
cadre de cette campagne nationale
communiquer votre désir de donner ou non
mais exprimez-vous sur cette question
c'est le but on va revoir l affiche pour
le centre hospitalier de versailles
juste pour une parenthèse car cette
affiche a été réalisée par des enfants
c'est en décembre
alors oui là c'était un énorme challenge
on a pensé on a sollicité les services
de pédiatrie
désormais on a discuté un petit peu avec
les membres de l'équipe qui dès le début
nous ont dit oulala
voilà ça peut-être pas être simple et
finalement s'est rendu compte que pour
les enfants
c'était tout à fait naturel on a mis
aussi dans la boucle des parents dont
les enfants ont fait on a sélectionné il
y avait beaucoup de dessins sélectionnés
celui ci avec arc en ciel qui nous a
semblé quand même le plus représentatif
et puis il ya eu d'autres desseins alors
les enfants ont fait beaucoup de
citations ont inventé beaucoup de
citations ses hésitations elle sera
accroché demain à des ballons qui vont
être là lancés dans le ciel y en aura 85
85 personnes que nous avons prélevé dans
les dix dernières années avait failli et
qui ont permis de faire plus de
quasiment 300 greffes ce sera organisée
demain sur le temps de midi le matin en
revanche il y aura également un stand
d'information et d'exposition et l'après
midi conférence débat ces programmes
pour le centre hospitalier programme
pour demain comment va ça va se passer
au niveau du débat parce qu'il ya
notamment une intervention regards
croisés sur la science éthique et droit
s'avère qu'il est question encore qu'ils
se posent sur ces trois éléments tout à
fait alors déjà il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se posent sur la
législation et puis au niveau de
l'éthique des questions par rapport aux
dons parce que est ce que le don
d'organes c'est vraiment un don puisque
en fait quand on donne quelque chose on
attend un remerciement là il ya plus de
possibilités de remerciement puisque
c'est dans le strict anonymat des
receveurs donc il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se pose de questions pardon qui se
posent à ce niveau là il y aura aussi
une intervention pour expliquer encore
la mort cérébrale parce
c'est pas quelque chose qui est très
connu et qui est pas très facile à
comprendre
si vous voulez plus d'informations
rendez vous au centre hospitalier ce
sera demain à versailles et puis nous en
reparlerons bien sûr dans notre édition
du soir merci à vous à pascal série tête
merci beaucoup sur ce plateau au revoir
culture à présent avec le château de
versailles qui a dévoilé le nom de
l'artiste retenu pour réaliser l'oeuvre
qui accueillera les visiteurs dont le
futur pavillon dufour à l'entrée du site
pavillon en cours de réalisation c'est
claude rutault connu pour son travail
conceptuel que vous allez apercevoir
dans un instant des toiles tendues
peintes de la même manière que les murs
sur lesquels sont disposés l'oeuvre sera
baptisé de la peinture
sir ce sera à découvrir début 2015 d'une
opération menée dans le cadre du 1 %
artistique qui oblige à décorer les
constructions publiques
et puis le château de versailles a reçu
un visiteur de taille samedi matin
l'ancien joueur de basket professionnel
basket américain shaquille o'neal 42 ans
2 m 16 et près de 150 kilos difficile de
le manquer forcément avec quelques fans
se sont empressés de prendre des photos
des diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux
shaquille o'neal c'est une vingtaine de
saison en tant que professionnel quatre
titres de champion des dizaines de
records après le mariage de kim
kardashian et du rappeur kanye west le
mois dernier le château de versailles
décidément très prisé par les
personnalités américaines musique 21
juin premier jour de l'été à cette
occasion amateurs de guitare batterie
saxophone et autres instruments se
retrouvent dans la rue pour célébrer la
musique également retour sur cette fête
de la musique 2014 dans les yvelines
avec eolen 13 et patrick jacques de
dixmude direction et l'encours et
montigny le bretonneux également
et non cette année l'arrivée de l'été
n'est pas la seule chose à fêter en ce
21 juin c'est aussi la fête de la
musique
elle encourt les habitants se sont
retrouvés quartier 17 mars au programme
du rock du hip hop ou encore du funk
tout cela réuni en a avec le groupe jack
fête de la musique c'est un evo un
événement important quand tu es musicien
est ce que c'est un endroit où un moment
par nous tu peux faire de la musique
partout donc c'est quelque chose en fait
qui devrait généraliser c'est presque un
peu triste qu'ils se soient juste un
seul jour dans l'année
à quelques mètres de là dans un tout
autre style la chorale crescendo
c'est très sympa ça anime la ville il ya
plein de choses diversifiée
on s'amuse bien il fait bon
direction montigny-le-bretonneux
ici aussi la fête de la musique bat son
plein dans le cadre du partenariat de la
ville à des danseuses irlandaise ou
moins fait le voyage pour l'occasion
c'est bien mais pour l'instant c'est un
passionne problème c'est très
divertissant
c'est très bien voir tous ces jeunes
pour qu'ils sont appliquées c'est très
bien c'est très agréable ici on est très
bien vendu dans le parc du château le
parc du château c'est en effet le choix
des organisateurs cette année entre les
associations les collectifs des villes
jumelées ou encore les groupes qui
arrivent en 2ème partie de soirée
il a fallu faire quelques sélections on
n'a pas pu prendre tout le monde parce
qu'il ya vraiment une offre énorme sur
le territoire de montigny beaucoup de
l'initiative de groupes qui jouent et
mais on s'assure d'essayer de faire
tourner ça un peu d'une année sur
l'autre bien sûr pour tout le monde soit
à peu près satisfait
c'est extraordinaire parce qu'on a
plusieurs sortes de musiques en fête
il ya plusieurs origines qui sont mêlés
donc voilà un peu plus tard dans la
soirée le conservatoire de musique de la
ville proposait son aide les des années
70 un peu stressé juste avant de monter
sur scène mais on va se défaire peace
and love
et
c'est une réunion humaine avant tout et
puis c'est fun c'est la fête il fait bon
haletant avec nous donc voilà ce que ça
représente pour moi
plus d'une centaine de personnes étaient
mobilisées pour cette fête de la musique
à montigny-le-bretonneux un travail
entamé depuis la fin de l'année dernière
à voir les sourires et les
applaudissements la mission semble
accomplie c'est le jour de la fête de la
musique a été choisi par l'association
artisans du monde et la boutique de
trappes pour organiser une braderie sur
les étals les clients pouvaient voyager
à travers les productions présentées
comme de la vaisselle du cameroun des
objets est d'indonésie encore du vietnam
des objets certes bradés cela ne
changeait rien aux prix qui a été payé à
l'artisan c'est le principe du commerce
équitable on écoute annick thomas c'est
les bénévoles présidente de
l'association à saint quentin en
yvelines
les producteurs de là bas ont été payés
pour 50% à la commande
c'est à dire que la voilà ils ont déjà
touché 50 % de ce qui arrivera en
novembre et les 50% restants c'est payé
quand ça arrive en france c'est à dire
en octobre à peu près puis après c'est
dédouaner ses réparties sur l'ensemble
des boutiques artisans du monde
non non ils ont pour eux le prix et fixe
dès le départ tous les objets sont du
commerce équitable
c'est à dire que les organisations de
producteurs on fixe le prix ensemble
cela les producteurs disent ah voilà
pour que je vivre correctement de mon
travail c'est en est on achète ce prix
là et puis après ben on essaie de vendre
le prix qui va avec voilà sport ce week
end le site de la boulie à versailles
accueillait la 30e édition du challenge
viala c'est une compétition nationale
jeunes de hockey sur gazon une
discipline où les clubs berlinois font
partie des meilleurs même si le sport
peine à décoller dans l'opinion publique
anthony rech
prenez deux équipes de six à onze
joueurs armés d'une crosse un terrain de
plus de 90 mètres de long et une balle
et vous avez un match de hockey sur
gazon mélangeant geste de tennis de
football et de gaulle
qu'est ce que paierait ce soir l'équipe
et on passe tout le temps la balle
chacun c'est beau à voir aussi ce que
j'aime bien
regardez les matchs tous les matchs
équipe première si les yvelines compte
deux des meilleurs clubs français avec
le racing et le champion de france saint
germain en laye la discipline pourtant
olympique reste encore méconnu avec
environ 17000 pratiquants en france au
racing on souhaite donc se tourner vers
les écoles pour recruter et avec un
argument de poids
on a besoin de dextérité on a un outil
dans les mains qui est qui est une
crasse et pareil on a besoin de beaucoup
de motricité entre la crasse dans les
mains
courir avec sept ans il met tout en
regardant un peu ses coéquipiers pour
faire des bonnes passes donc on les
enfants c'est plutôt un très beau score
pour passer un cap
un club comme le racing tente d'attirer
d'importants sponsors mais face à des
disciplines populaires comme le football
le combat s'annonce très compliquée
c'est un cercle
on essaie de mettre en place qui est pas
simple puisque vous avez certes un sport
qui prennent 80 voire 90 % de l'audience
médiatique et nous l'objectif
effectivement c'est d'imaginer pourquoi
pas un rapprochement avec d'autres
sports avec d'autres sections pas
suffisamment médiatisé pour créer du
contenu mutualisés à l'heure actuelle le
hockey est l'un des trois sports les
plus médiatisés au monde
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv fils
prochaine édition du 7 8 l'aktu demain
mardi 24 juin même heure l'intégralité
de ce journal est à retrouver sur notre
site internet grâce au replay bonne
soirée